[Music]
look closely this is what a wildlife
poacher on the run looks like this is
the view through a thermal infrared
camera being used by Rangers at a
Conservation Park in kenya wildlife
poaching is a huge problem just last
year 1,200 of the 25 thousand rhinos
left in South Africa were killed for
their horns rhino and elephant
populations have been particularly
hard-hit over the last decade now World
Wildlife Fund has teamed up with the
thermal imaging company fleer to watch
over endangered animals 24 hours a day
clears thermal imaging cameras pick up
the heat signature of anything that
moves in front of their lenses animal or
human WWF working with a grant from
google has sent up a test of thermal
imaging tech here at Kenya's Masai Mara
Conservancy and another at an
undisclosed Park that's home to rhinos
some cameras are mounted on poles while
others are set up on vehicles are
carried as handheld scopes the
technology can see as far as a mile the
thermal imaging says WWF gives Rangers
the literal ability to see in the dark
and that's the upper hand in this
critical game of hide-and-seek the fixed
position cameras feed back to a central
command where an artificial intelligence
algorithm trained to detect human
movement keeps a digital eye out for
poachers and when it sees them Rangers
can swoop in and catch the perpetrators
already the tech has been used to stop
26 poachers now the WWF is putting
thermal imaging on drones giving
wildlife protectors eyes and the night
skies so you can run poachers but you
can't hide
[Music]
you